en medio de los horrores de la guerra
siempre están los civiles y la invasión
rusa de ucraniano es una excepción
amnistía internacional publicó un
informe donde señala esta vez a las
fuerzas ucranianas después de meses de
investigación pueden afirmar que el
ejército de kiev puso en peligro a la
población civil al establecer bases
militares en escuelas y hospitales de
las regiones de jarquín nikoláy y el
donbass también concluyen que las
fuerzas ucranianas operaron sistemas
militares desde áreas residenciales y
pobladas convirtiendo a los civiles ya
su infraestructura en un objetivo
militar para el ejército ruso
desde kiev rechazaron tajantemente el
informe
estoy impactado como todos por la
declaración de amnistía internacional la
consideró injusta el comportamiento de
amnistía internacional no tiene nada que
ver con la investigación y la
comunicación de la verdad en el mundo un
falso balance sino que trata de crear
una falsa equivalencia entre agresor y
víctima
james entre un país que destruye
centenares de miles de civiles y un país
que se defiende desesperadamente
bisenius no pero la respuesta de
amnistía internacional es firme estar en
una posición defensiva no exenta al
ejército ucraniano de respetar el
derecho internacional humanitario la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania no para
mientras el lado ucraniano teme una
nueva ofensiva militar en person las
facciones pro rusas de donges
denunciaron la muerte de cinco personas
en su territorio por bombardeos
ucranianos
a pocos kilómetros pero al otro lado de
la línea de frente en la ciudad de hama
torch algunos vecinos esperan que llegue
la ofensiva rusa
recibieron órdenes de evacuar pero por
edad o por dinero no han podido en un
mercado callejero venden las pocas
pertenencias que les quedan para comer
bien o para comprar pan y agua o para
amenizar la espera que va que van a
vodka y cerveza